the Subscribe button flashes its
momentary Beacon the like button
flickering as it points its thumb up the
video ends and YouTube Auto plays
another and the monkeys watch they don't
question they sit they consume now has
changed the truth we've on Earth will
leave you seeing things through new eyes
we are obsolete so ask yourself this how
does it feel in a theory becomes a fact
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that wants you to think really
really hard about clicking that
subscribe button harder harder you know
what I think it worked today we're
returning to the terrifying world of the
Mandela catalog an analog horror series
created by Alex kister right here on
youtube.com in case you're just catching
up the story takes place in Mandela
County a fictional part of Wisconsin
where an unknown man called the Intruder
keeps appearing on TV causing children
to suddenly vanish now that alone would
be terrifying but in addition to weird
televised kidnappers the world is also
dealing with a race of creepy
doppelgangers called alternates Twisted
beings that drive people insane and
cause a lot of death before going on to
steal their identities in short the
world Alex is building here brings
together tons of big ideas from religion
horror and old school science fiction
and then mixes it with a visual style
that's one part Blair Witch one part
Playstation One era cutscene and a
little veggie tale nightmare fuel thrown
in on the side for flavor since our last
Theory Allah lot has happened in this
universe there have been two brand new
volumes uploaded onto Alex's Channel an
entire ARG website that's come and gone
even a couple of videos covering the
element most crucial to solving this
thing the plushies that's right friendos
Mark the occasion for the first time
ever in 12 years of theorizing we got
ourselves some plushies lore because
this is gonna be the thing that cracks
the whole series wide open but in all
seriousness it is actually gonna play an
important role in the theory that we
have coming out today so today in a
series where there's a lot of characters
and a lot of stuff going on I want to
focus on the big picture stuff who is
the Intruder what are the alternates why
is there an early 2000s amateur ghost
hunting crew mixed up with all of this
and how is it possibly relevant to all
the biblical interdimensional stuff that
keeps popping up well my friends I
suspect that all of it is a battle over
a man who will become the future of the
human race we've got a lot to cover
today loyal theorists so pop in your
Contraband VHS tape it's time to watch
so one of the biggest and most obvious
unanswered questions about the series is
what's going on with all its religious
imagery since its very first upload
overthrown the Mandela catalogs
Incorporated animated biblical stories
into its narrative but we're not talking
about your typical Sunday school lessons
here friends these are a bit off across
the uploads we watch Being known as
Gabriel infiltrate classic biblical
stories from Adam and Eve to Noah and
the Ark each time he comes bearing an
important and seemingly dangerous
message
kill something ghf your mind what you've
seen you've seen it there is no return
but Gabriel here isn't just sending
messages down from on high he's
determined to get his hands dirty in the
most recent upload volume 4 we see that
Gabriel is a literal being that can
manifest in reality communicate with
normal humans and then kill the people
he encounters
now in earlier theories I suspected that
Gabriel might be some sort of alien
taking the shape of an angel that might
seem strange but in the first ever
upload of the series we actually get
this brief glimpse of a strange alien
face that eventually gets censored and
while I suspect that still may be true
what is undeniable now at this point in
the series is that Gabriel is also this
story stand-in for the devil he is this
world's version of Satan at the
beginning of volume 4 we see a retelling
of the biblical story of Genesis and we
speed run through all the highlights the
formation of the world in seven days the
division of land and sea the creation of
man in the form of Adam and Eve and
their eventual Downfall with they're
convinced to eat an apple from the Tree
of knowledge which prompts God to eat
them out of paradise now in most
retellings of the story a snake is the
one who offers the Apple a snake that is
symbolic of Satan himself tempting man
and causing their downfall but here in
the Mandela catalog's version of events
Gabriel is the one that's responsible
for this thereby equating him with Satan
this suddenly makes a lot of other
details about the series click into
place for example in the upload
exhibition Gabriel tells Noah to bring
an unexpected passenger on the ark one
that will carry a secret message the
screen then goes dark and the audio goes
silent but the closed captions continue
with a hidden message they reference 2
Corinthians 11 14 quote and no wonder
for Satan disguises himself as an angel
of Light that is literally what's
happening here Gabriel is disguising
himself as a very traditional looking
Renaissance Era statuesque Angel Satan
is disguised additionally we see the
number 333 show up multiple times
throughout the series as both the title
of the third upload volume 333 as well
as the a highway exit that leads to
Mandela County again Gabriel being Satan
disguised as an angel of Light ties all
of that together 333 is often considered
to be the number of angels and it
references how three is a holy number to
a lot of Christians because it
represents the Trinity God split between
three entities the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit but 333 is also half of
666 the Number of the beasts often
associated with Satan so the number
Works symbolically in multiple ways
Mandela is a town controlled by this
evil angel 333 the number of angels but
it's also a marker for an on-ramp to
Satan's domain so what then is Gabriel's
plan what is his evil message well
basically Gabriel's a symbol that
weaponizes religion he's made it so that
religion that the church itself is a
cult and we know this based on the most
recent upload in volume 4 there's an
ongoing thread of conversation between
Dave Lee owner of a failing video store
and his friend O'Brien a guy who plays
in a band and offers to get Dave a job
at the local church if his video store
gig falls through Dave Begins the upload
by rejecting his offer I'm not a man of
God
hey no
no you can always let me know
Flash Forward two years later though and
the store actually has to close
prompting Dave to have a change of heart
Dave covers up his TV symbolizing him
turning his back on technology and his
old way of doing things before he heads
off to the church to meet with his
friend but there he's locked out when he
calls O'Brien to let him in Gabriel
appears and Gabriel uses the same words
that O'Brien just said to him over the
phone stay still you were so close David
O'Brien was an agent of Gabriel Dave is
killed because he ultimately turned to
religion he's now yet another victim of
Gabriel's as for O'Brien he was yet
another example of this world's
alternates the creepy elongated beings
with their ability to mimic humans
and we now know that alternates are
confirmed to be Gabriel's minions
recently the Creator Alex kister
launched a merch campaign releasing an
official makeshift figurine of Gabriel
where the character is described as
quote the harbinger of evil and the
first alternate but while he may have
been the first his alternate Army has
been spreading that message to Noah as
they prepare to board the ark The Entity
that's hopping on board is likely an
early alternate in the merch drop
Gabriel is also described as a hive mind
leader so all the other alternates are
parts of him come to think of it maybe
Gabriel really is an alien after all
because all of this sounds a lot like
John Carpenter's classic horror flick
the thing in that film an alien is
uncovered in Antarctica that's able to
shape-shift and steal the identities of
the people that it touches adding them
to its hive mind sounds a lot like what
Gabriel's doing throughout Mandela and
it's here where we find our second big
question about the series if alternates
are such a big threat why is the
government not doing anything about them
the world is oddly complacent about
these creatures that are stealing
identities and in the process kill
killing thousands so again what is going
on well based on the evidence it seems
likely that the government has been
infiltrated by Gabriel and his
alternates let me explain the earliest
government record of alternates that we
see in the series appears in the form of
a 1980s public service announcement from
the U.S department of temporal phenomena
here they warn people to keep every
entrance to their home secured and to
keep a firearm on them at all times for
self-defense in fact all civilians are
encouraged to fight back against the
alternates while we heavily discourage
any form of contact or communication
with an alternate we make exceptions for
attempts at executing them yourself by
the 1990s though the tactics definitely
seem to have changed police Dispatchers
in Mandela County are actively told not
to help callers reporting alternate
attacks in fact they're told to actively
lie to tell the caller that everything's
gonna be okay then wait until the caller
stops responding presumably after they
die it's certainly a far cry from the
earlier advice of kill it with fire
another decade later during the portion
of the story that takes place in the
late late 2000s the government now seems
to be actively targeting people looking
into or interfering with alternates we
see in volume 2 that two characters
named Adam and Jonah are wanted by the
FBI because they're possibly associated
with the bithorn Paranormal Society a
group of Ghost Hunters who sometimes
search for alternates why would the FBI
of all people be interested in a bunch
of young kids looking into the existence
of ghosts unless they were trying to
silence anyone who might learn the truth
about the alternate threat it's also at
this point in the timeline after a
decade plus of complete an action when
people have just totally given up on
government officials helping with pretty
much anything in this world but it's not
like anyone's going to call the cops
here and the mayor was just too stupid
to just make that entire uh infographics
these massive changes in messaging and
how to deal with alternates would make
sense if the government Were Somehow in
on Gabriel's plan either infected by his
message or with key people in positions
of power replaced by alternates so
Gabriel is literally the devil and he's
using his army of alternates to
infiltrate the police and gov and that
being said one thing that's still
unclear to me in the series is just how
widespread the alternate threat is for
there to be an entire government agency
like the U.S department of temporal
phenomena issuing warnings about how to
prevent the alternate threat that would
seem to suggest that these things are
nationwide but so far everything we've
seen from the series has been local to
Mandela and its surrounding counties it
seems so localized in fact that one
character we meet even questions whether
alternates are real
there aren't even alternates maybe it's
Mass hysteria right I suspect what we're
witnessing here are the beginnings of
the alternate's global takeover their
start in Mandela the epicenter of
activity and subsequent spread to other
nearby counties a spread that's being
slowed or even outright halted by the
other key figure in the series and the
other major mystery that's going on here
the Intruder the mysterious man and the
TV responsible for stealing kids out of
their homes and doing well we were never
quite sure about what he was doing at
least we weren't until now you see with
the most recent upload I think we now
know the answer to this one too one of
the strangest sections from volume 333
is an extended segment taken from a
mysterious short film called might of
the subconscious a film made by a
production company that's impossible to
track down we know that fact thanks to
an ARG website that launched earlier
this year in might of the subconscious
we meet Stanley a face made out of
simple white lines who claims to want
new friends consider me a friend because
I might consider you one too given
Stanley's tone this is clearly meant to
be shown to children as he goes on
though things become a bit strange as
Stanley claims to be able to I can make
friends appear out of thin air he asks
the viewer to imagine every detail of
their ideal friend then in a segment
that glitches out Stanley says if there
is a new friend that lives in your head
it is best it is festive it is best as
the subtitles continue and complete the
sentence to say to manifest them instead
at the end of the segment Stanley says
that he thinks it worked and that the
new friend is somewhere in the house
it's at that point we hard cut to a
police call of someone panicked of an
intruder in their home your new friend
is somewhere in your house now it's up
to you to go and find them 911 what's
your emergency please
an alternate has been manifested the
caller disappears and Ruth Weaver one of
the police investigators ultimately
winds up kill but with Stanley who would
have the power to summon Twisted
monsters like this it's the Intruder in
volume 4 the Intruder basically confirms
that he was Stanley all along
can you remember
this also plays into the intruder's use
of televisions he's using him to show
his face to as many people as possible
cementing his creepy features in their
minds and then the old videotape is
basically a tutorial for children to
literally think him and his alternates
into reality which now sets the stage
for the big picture story that's going
on in the Mandela catalog a story of two
competing false gods a false god within
religion in the form of Gabriel and
another false god within the television
the Intruder an alternate who's gone
Rogue from Gabriel's Army and the two of
them are constantly trading blows while
Gabriel replaces people with alternate
Twisted versions of themselves the
Intruder counters by manifesting into
our reality and snatching children away
before they can be corrupted or Worse
see though this doesn't apply in every
denomination several sects of
Christianity view dying in the way that
alternates and lives a sin a sin that
Dooms the soul to he double hockey
sticks and if Gabriel is Satan well
wouldn't that mean that he gets more
powerful with every life ended in this
way that would also explain why some of
the instructor actions given by the
department of temporal phenomena in
their think initiative tell civilians to
because there's not enough room for the
two of us it's the government under
Gabriel's control giving directions that
make Gabriel more powerful Gabriel also
counters the Intruder by having the
usdtp order all TV screens and mirrors
be destroyed rendering the screen
hopping Intruder useless and this
campaign also winds up wildly successful
seeing old TVs turned on is a big deal
in this world enough so that one
character keeps an old CRT television
hidden under a blanket in his closet
like Contraband claiming it's the last
one in the entire state of Wisconsin but
why sure maybe these forces are just
duking it out for some sort of control
but aren't they both alternates why
aren't they working together what's the
big inciting incident here well it all
comes down to one character Adam Murray
in case you need a reminder because
there are a lot of characters in the
series Adam is one of our point of view
characters he's a Ghost Hunter and the
person that we see messaging on a brand
neutral AOL Instant Messenger throughout
volume 4. basically we see almost all
the parts of the the story set in the
late 2000s through Adam's eyes and
there's a very good reason for that you
see Adam is important to everyone in the
Mandela catalog he's important enough to
the government that he's wanted by the
FBI with a 100
000 reward on his head he's important to
Gabriel enough so that he sends several
alternates after him as he hunts a ghost
cat in rural Wisconsin and he's
important enough to the Intruder that he
basically Engineers an entire face
generation software so he can manifest
and speak in the real world
Adam is an alternate but completely
unlike any other alternate that we've
seen thus far no one can tell that he's
an alternate heck he can't tell that
he's an alternate in the world of the
Mandela catalog he's something
completely new and if all of this is
indeed the case we can actually take
things just a step further there's one
thing that Alex gister hasn't been it's
subtle in his choice of symbolic imagery
throughout the series this young man
here is named Adam his girlfriend
another important character in the
series is named Evelyn Evelyn just like
in the biblical story they are likely to
start a new race of humans but now the
question is who are they gonna follow
will they follow the false god of
religion Gabriel will they follow the
false god of the TV the Intruder or
maybe there's actually a third option
one that doesn't involve Twisted human
doppelgangers in the first place you see
throughout volume 4 Evelyn starts to
realize that there's something off about
Adam she discovers records in the police
department that Adam isn't exactly like
all the other kids that he's an
alternate made from an encounter that he
had with the Intruder when he was a baby
in other words she has now bitten from
the apple of Enlightenment she now knows
the truth in the original Bible story
after Eve bites the Apple Adam is given
a choice he can either choose God and
stand the Garden of Eden or choose Eve
knowledge and get yeeded out of paradise
it looks like the Mandela catalog might
be setting up a similar situation evil
confront Adam with the knowledge of what
he truly is and it'll be up to him to
decide what he wants to become will he
follow Gabriel the leader of the
alternate hive mind the Intruder and
Alternate gone Rogue who basically gave
him life or will he choose Humanity that
I suspect is what we're gearing up for
in the series there is so much else
going on here in the Mandela catalog and
again I have to say Alex has done an
amazing job building such a fascinating
world and taking his time to tell a
really awesome story even now three
theories and we still have so much left
to explore and believe me we will be
digging into all of that soon enough so
in the meantime why don't you subscribe
so you don't miss the next time we take
a trip back to Mandela County and if you
want to watch another theory that
tackles deeply disturbing analog horror
lore click the video to see on screen
right now for our episode on the
mysterious oh whoa see since that video
I've learned how to pronounce it
appropriately and as always remember my
friends until the next one it's all just
a theory a film Theory and cut